Let's go to nine one nine Yang guy who is
voting for Biden, nine one nine Yang guy voting
for Biden.
Does that does that ring a bell?
Yeah.
Hey, David, how you doing?
Hey, how are you?
I'm doing all right.
I just want to know what you think is the.
The best way for us to make some positive
change as progressive under the Biden administration.
Beautiful.
OK.
Excellent.
So let's imagine November 3rd, assuming we
know the results on November 3rd, we may not.
November 3rd, Donald Trump is removed.
It is the end of an era and the start of starting
to the start of fixing the reputation and
infrastructure and governmental functioning
of the United States with the election of
Joe Biden.
Okay, very optimistic scenario.
That moment, the David Pakman show becomes
a show not about removing Trump, but about
making Biden the most progressive that we
possibly can.
So the question is a beautiful question.
So as soon as this happens, we have to put
pressure on Biden to actually do the executive
orders that he has said he would do when he
gets elected president.
Every one of the changes he's promised to
health care, we need to push for immediately
and then push for more in the midterms of
2022.
We need to make the House and hopefully the
Senate as left as we possibly can.
I mean, it's like the way I see it is when,
if and when Joe Biden replaces Donald Trump.
That's not the end.
That's the start when it comes to the progressive
movement, which has been playing defense for
a long time now because of Donald Trump.
We get.
We haven't had the ball yet.
Right in that.
So it's like, imagine a football game where
we could potentially get the ball back in
November.
We've got to then start calling the right
plays to use a sports metaphor.
OK.
Yeah, they were separate.
I'm thinking about like as far as everyone
started to buy V.P. pick and I think that
the best one to get some progressive change
at this point would be Elizabeth Warren.
And I just wonder if when we do flip the Senate
and everything that we do have the ball, if,
you know, the politicians and us will be able
to actually get stuff done as opposed to like
returning to the Obama years.
Well, that's going to be up to us.
That's gonna be up to us.
It's going to be up to who we elect at the
state level, who we put in place in the Senate
and in the House of Representatives.
So the fight will hopefully begin on January
21st.
Let's hope so.
Let's.
All right, my friend.
Thanks for the call very much.
Appreciate it.
That's a Yang guy who has decided that he
must vote for Joe Biden.
That that is the right thing to do.
Let's go next to our caller from the nine
seven eight area code.
Caller from nine seven eight.
What's your name and where are you calling
from?
I'm calling from Westminster, Massachusetts.
Westminster.
Where is that?
We are in central mass, really?
20, 30 minutes away from Western, depending
how fast you grow.
Oh, all right.
I would have imagined that was the five oh
wait area code out there.
Not now.
Now we're like a little farm town.
All right.
What's going on?
Well, I just wanted to know what your take
was on the recent conflicts have been bubbling
over with China and India alongside the bombing
of the Diplomat Center and the DMZ.
And if you think that there is a plausible
scenario where we might blunder into another
global military conflict.
You know, I this could be me being naive,
but I actually feel pretty confident that
it is not going to blow over into a major
conflict, the likes of which you're suggesting.
But I do think that, you know, we can't control
who's in power in China or in India, nor should
we.
But, yeah, I would feel better if we had someone
with a steady or hand running the United States
than Donald Trump.
And obviously, there's going to be a lot that
happens before Joe Biden could even possibly
be sworn in.
If he were to win in November.
So I am hopefully not naively confident that
this is not going to blow up.
But I would feel better if we had.
I mean, listen, you can say a lot of things
about Joe Biden.
He's not super progressive.
Do we need another 78 year old?
You know, all this stuff, Joe Biden, in terms
of diplomacy and knowledge of China and India,
blows Trump out of the water by a hundred
times.
We may not agree with all of Joe Biden's conclusions,
but I think Biden's instincts would would
be the right ones when it comes to that region
in preventing this type of conflict.
He may not do what we like on trade.
I mean, I'm not saying Biden's great on China,
period, but he's a steady hand and he's a
diplomat.
And I would feel better having him in the
mix than Donald Trump.
Right.
I agree.
One of the major concerns that I have with
this, like in its entirety, was that, you
know, all the all the, you know, progress
that I'm president now made with, you know,
actually trying to bring more of, like, you
know, economic flourishing to North Korea.
And then all of a sudden all that like, you
know, even just the optics of this and walking
over past the DMZ into North Korea to fight
for the first time.
And like now they're pretty much saying, no,
screw that.
You know, we didn't get what we wanted.
Not feel like Trump's ego is going to get
ahead of him and he might do something stupid.
That's about right.
We'll listen from the get go.
All of these right wingers who were saying,
you know, people are making fun of Trump,
but he knows what he's doing when it comes
to sort of North Korea.
He's gotten concessions and he's made more
progress than this, that only someone who
completely misunderstands or doesn't know
the history of relations with North Korea
could have imagined that Trump was actually
exhibiting it or being party to some major
breakthrough with North Korea.
And obviously that in the last two years,
that's been proven to be the case.
So, yeah, I mean, if you're waiting around
for Trump to be the guy that solves that situation,
it's obviously not going to be.
Yeah, of course.
All right, my friend.
Thank you so much, appreciate the question.
Great to hear from you.
Let's take a quick break.
But if you're holding, don't hang up unless
you want to get off the phone, because I am
going to be going right back to the phones
after this short break